hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
- have you ever wondered how was food
and take regulated why am I always
hungry so when my last video I speak to
you about the role of genetics in weight
gain and I introduced you to the
concepts and the use of genome-wide
Association studies and I showed you
this nature paper here that looks at
genome-wide Association study for body
mass index and genetic variance now
studies like this in combination with
other monogenic cases of obesity have
highlighted the key players in the
regulation of food intake one of these
which I mentioned last time is leptin
the hormone secreted from adipose tissue
through binding to its receptor in the
brain it stimulates energy expenditure
and reduces the desire for fiber food
intake but what is this mysterious
signaling process this is what I will
discuss in this video so many different
genes were identified from the
genome-wide Association study that I've
listed here FTO
is the most significant out of these but
here I will discuss Ponzi and mc4r
because they are involved in a
regulation of food intake so let's start
with pom C so pom C stands for Pro APA
melanocortin and it is up regulated in
response collective so how does this
happen
so when you've just eaten leptin is
going to be secreted by adipose tissue
and so it goes up to the brain as I
explained before and it binds to its
receptors and this regulates the
expression of pom Zee in pom C neurons
and so what happens is you increase
expression of pom C and this these pom C
neurons are in the hypothalamus which is
a region of the brain in to be more
specific it's in the arcuate nucleus of
the hypothalamus and so when you have
leptin you increase poms expression and
then downstream of that you were going
to prevent food intake and promote
energy expenditure but how does Ponzi
achieve this
stay ponzi is a protein that gets
chopped up and it gets chopped up into
different smaller peptides and they have
different function the key peptides that
I'm going to talk about here is alpha
MSH which stands for alpha melanocytes
stimulating hormone so alpha MSH binds
to its own receptor and that receptor is
mc4r which is another one at the low
site associated gene so mc4r stands for
milani Courtin for receptor and so mc4r
is part of a really large family of
protein receptors called g-protein
coupled receptors or GPC are so short
and what is really unique about these
g-protein coupled receptors is that they
have seven transmembrane domains as you
can see in this little sketch here well
it looks a bit better in my second
sketch so the key thing is that these
are receptors that are at the membrane
so the alpha MSH can come and interact
with the receptor and that interaction
activates the downstream signaling of
this receptor and say what is the
response of that downstream signaling
yeah you're right
it's the prevention of food intake and
promotion of energy expenditure so let's
summarize what we've covered so far
so breeland's about leptin and how it
interacts with its receptor and how that
occurs in the hypothalamus of the brain
from that it activates or a previous
expression of palsy in the pom c neurons
pom c can then get broken down one
chopped up two different peptides one of
which is alpha melanocytes stimulating
hormone that binds to the mc4r receptor
and this has the effect of stimulating
energy expenditure and preventing food
intake but the situation is a little bit
more complicated than I've told you so
far so lapsing receptors are not just
found on the pom c neurons there are an
awful class of neurons called
beauty-related protein neurons as you
can see a TRP here and this has the
effect of preventing the expression of
do
mutilated protein and so this protein
does
it's the antagonist of comc and prevents
an activation of mc4r
so when you've got lapped in your
reduced expression of decontaminated
protein and hence you get rid of that
negative repression in addition to
leptin you also have another hormone
called ghrelin which is kind of like the
opposite leptin and we had gone like
peptide one is another hormone and that
kind of work so relieved to you leptin
but the key thing is the situation is
just way more complicated than I believe
dated here so far so fastly
in terms of actually understanding the
bad chemistry behind this regulation
system most of the studies have been
done on mice not humans so how do we
know if this is translatable to our
ancestors secondly I've drawn this
pathway out as a linear pathway but
actually the situation is probably
better assembled as like a spider web of
interactions thirdly the hypothalamus is
not the only area of the brain that is
directly related to regulating food
intake there are other areas of the
brain that are important to you and
related to this there are other neurons
that have the leptin receptor and lastly
whilst we know that the brain is a
highly dynamic golden we are still
pretty uncertain about the role of these
different genes and the protein products
in development of the brain and how that
can affect adult life so if you are
interested in finding out more about
this topic I highly recommend reading
this for a few article that goes into
more detail about the different
components of this regulatory system of
food intake and just to highlight a more
recent example this paper looks at
genetic variants in the mc4r
receptor protein that I talks about and
how different variants have been found
that either have an increased function
or a decrease function and that can
impact the body mass index so I hope
from this video that you now have a much
better understanding of how food intake
is regulated